hey youtubers is charlie so Game of
Thrones just left us this early
Christmas present is a teaser for Game
of Thrones season 6 it's like the first
teaser poster image so what does this
mean so I'm just going to say broad
spoiler warning for everything through
season 5 on Game of Thrones and there
actually is a new round of the giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a twenty-dollar amazon
gift card so here we go what's going on
here is HBO isn't saying that Jon Snow
is alive they're definitely telling the
truth when they say dead is dead I can't
remember which executive said it I think
it was the president of HBO at the tcas
this year where of course he got the
question is jon snow coming back his kit
harington coming back to the show and he
said all i know is dead is dead so what
does that mean that just means that Jon
Snow did in fact died during that for
the watch scene at the end of season 5
but it's what happens after he dies the
HBO was not talking about so you can
poke fun at the game of thrones or the
HBO people as much as you want but
technically they weren't lying and of
course there has been kit harington hair
watch if you don't know what that is it
just you know people judging the status
of Jon Snow based on kit Harrington's
here kit harington said that when he
signed on for season one in Game of
Thrones he was not allowed to ever cut
his hair he had to keep it Jon Snow
length so of course when he was killed
off hair watch began like the minute he
cut his hair that would have been
confirmation that he's not coming back
to the show because if you're not going
to wear a wig then it takes a long time
to grow hair back but if you've been
watching Game of Thrones the last couple
of seasons even if you haven't read the
books you know that when a new season
starts it usually picks up in the
moments after the previous season finale
so of course we see jon snow gets
stabbed by all of his brothers the
Nights Watch it stands to reason that he
would have to come back for at least a
couple moments at the beginning of
season six so they could address what
happens to his body do they burn it to
the wildlings take it does mellow Sandra
take it to someone else take it so even
if you took the show at face value and
you thought that Jon Snow is dead kit
harington the actor would have to come
back to address what happens after his
death but here's my big question for you
guys book readers and show Watchers did
you either read this moment with Jon
Snow at the end of Dance with Dragons or
see it on the TV show and take it at
face value did you assume that he was
dead and not
coming back and if so why did you think
that he was not coming back at all I
feel like what ended up happening is is
we all had this shared moment when we
saw on the show even if you read the
books and you knew it was coming you
still kind of share this moment with
everyone in the world where you're like
oh my god what do they you know what are
we gonna do now how are they going to
bring him back because we haven't had
winds of winter yet so even if you've
read the books you don't know what's
going to happen to them in moments of
crisis like that usually your brain goes
into survival mode and you start trying
to find a way out of the situation so
it's like wait a minute how could he
survive this maybe they're lying to us
maybe he will wake up in the beginning
of season six but they started doing
interviews and even at comic-con the
person who directed the episode was like
yeah we played it like he was dead we
are definitely sure that Jon Snow died
so you really have to start looking at
the clues outside of the show and that's
really where you take the experience to
the nth degree like the way I typically
experience that the TV shows in the
movies and the things that I really
enjoy as if it's this giant continuum
where the story unfolds based on new
information every day so like I'll hear
things about a show or a story that will
change the way that I thought about it
before so it kind of unfolds in real
time like you don't wait for the next
season of the show to start like that's
the literal text then you have the
subtext where you know you pull out
meaning from cryptic clues then there's
the stuff that you see from the set the
things that the actors say in interviews
but even if you don't read all that
stuff there's still a lot of
foreshadowing in the books for what Jon
Snow's fate is going to be I did do a
video all about resurrection in A Song
of Ice and Fire so i'll put a link in
the description but less to say the show
has held back on some big resurrections
like some notable characters that it
hasn't done probably in service of this
Jon Snow twist just so that it seems
like a bigger deal so if you wonder why
there hasn't been Lady Stoneheart it's
probably just in the name of simplicity
just so they don't have to deal with all
these extra scenes and so this big jon
snow twist is a much bigger deal but the
funny thing is is they kind of already
tip their hat with beric Dondarrion the
Lord of Light brought him back six times
six times so when you think about how
laughably fast Melisandre made it from
that area near Winterfell up to the wall
like she made it in less than a day why
would the producers bend time and space
for her in such a hilarious way if her
presence near Jon Snow's death weren't
an important
I haven't spoken a lot about it but
Westeros is actually a really big place
they compressed time on the show when
characters are traveling from place to
place just to speed the narrative along
it would have taken Melisandre almost a
week to make it back to the wall but she
did it within the span of the day and I
don't think that she use blood magic to
make her horse run faster but the real
question now is how is jon snow coming
back I mean is Melisandre gonna go lay
hands on him is he just going to wake up
on his own I do think her presence is
required even if Jon Snow is going to be
a tool of the red God or receive his
boon then I think a red priest is
necessary but here's another big
question for you guys after you saw Jon
Snow get stabbed what was your rationale
for how he would come back did you think
he would work into ghosts did you think
that the White Walkers would co-opt him
I felt like of all the least likely
things to happen that would have been a
lot of fun but I do think in the grand
scheme of things jon snow will be a
character to fight for good regardless
of what ends up happening to him in the
end sometimes when your theory crafting
I feel like it helps if you combine show
things and book things like you can't
take just the books because there's so
much extra stuff that could lead you in
different directions the TV show is much
more linear it cuts out a lot of the
extra stuff so if you combine clues from
the books and from the show you know you
think about r + l equals J there's a
little bit of confirmation for that and
some of the things that Littlefinger
said this season as well stuff we've
seen from the set or at least Tower of
joy things I wouldn't say it's
confirmation of our plus l equals J even
though I still believe that but let us
all get hype and no I'm not expecting
any big trailer or anything like that
for season six at least till februari
next year that's around when the season
five trailer posted and if you guys
didn't know Game of Thrones season 6
won't premiere till much later in April
what's happening is is they're starting
a show called vinyl it's going to push
into the beginning of April so it's
bumping game of thrones by just a little
bit so I'm not expecting season 6 2
premiere to like the third week in April
which is just like a couple weeks later
than it normally airs it just means the
finale might spill into July and for
those of you asking about the winds of
winter I do think that george RR martin
is going to finish wins a winter
sometime before season 6 premieres but
there hasn't been any official
confirmation like I tweeted this picture
but this was just a fan picture this is
an official if it does come out before
season six starts it's actually going to
be really hard to try and
work that into my TV show videos without
doing crazy spoilers so we will talk
about wins the winter things next year
but I'll just have to figure out how to
deal with spoilers because a lot of TV
shows are on break this week I'll
probably have time for a game of thrones
Q&A so post all your questions in the
comments and if you guys haven't been
watching it Jessica Jones is awesome I'm
going to be posting my next jessica
jones video pretty soon there is like a
star wars special that's happening
tonight if there's anything cool that
comes out of that I'll totally do a
video for it to a whole bunch of Game of
Thrones whole bunch of Star Wars whole
bunch of Marvel stuff happening this
week while you guys wait for everything
to post you can click here to learn all
about resurrection on Game of Thrones
and all my other season six bonus videos
and you can click here for all my
Jessica Jones videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you